the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so I apologize my voice oh it's not 100%
so if you don't understand what I'm
saying please ask me so we're gonna be
analyzing actually not really analyzing
we described a second order method to
optimize the log-likelihood in a
generalized linear model when the
parameter of interest was beta okay so
here I'm gonna rewrite the whole thing
as a beta so that's the equation you see
but we really have this beta and an
iteration k plus 1 beta is given by beta
k and then I have a plus sign and the
plus if you think of the Fisher
information that beta K as being some
number if you were to say whether it's a
positive or a negative number it's
actually going to be a positive number
because it's a positive semi-definite
matrix so since we're doing gradient
descent we have a plus sign here and
then the direction is basically gradient
i'll and advaita k okay
so this is the iterations that we're
trying to implement and we could just do
this at its interation we compute the
Fisher information and then we do it
again and again
alright that's called the Fisher scoring
algorithm and I told you that this was
going to converge and what we're gonna
try to do this in this lecture is to
show how we can reimplemented using
iteratively re-weighted least squares so
that each step of this algorithm is
consists simply of solving a weighted
least square problem all right so let's
go back quickly and remind ourselves
that we are in the gaussian sorry we're
in the exponential family so if i look
at the log likelihood for one
observation
so here it's Ln sorry this is the sum
from I equal 1 to n of Y I - okay so
it's Y I times theta I sorry - B of
theta I then there's gonna be some
parameter and then I have plus C of Y I
Phi ok so just the exponential one
when I took the log of the likelihood
and I have an observation swim summing
over all n observations all right then
we had a bunch of formulas that we came
up to be safe a look at the expectation
of Y I so that's really the conditional
of why I give an X i but like here it
really doesn't matter it it's just gonna
be different for each I this is denoted
by mu I and we showed that this was been
a prime of theta I then the other
equation that we found was that so what
we want to model is this thing we want
it to be equal to X I transpose beta I
sorry G of this thing all right so
that's our model and then we had that
variance was also given by the second
derivative I'm not gonna go into it
what's actually interesting is to see if
we want to express beta I as a function
of X I what we get going from X I to
through 2 mu I by G inverse and then 2
theta I by B inverse we get that theta I
is equal to H of X I transpose beta
sorry yeah H of X I transpose beta where
H is the inverse so which order is this
is the inverse of G and I'm composed
with D prime ok so we remember that last
time those are all computation that
we've made they're gonna be useful in
our derivation and the first thing we
did last time is to sure if I look now
at the derivative of the log likelihood
with respect to one coordinate of beta
which is going to give me the gradient
if I do that for all the coordinates
what we ended up finding is that we can
rewrite it in this form some of why I
tell da - mute tilde so let's remind
ourselves that so Y tilde is just Y
divided well okay Y tilde I is why I as
it times R divided
G prime of knew I knew tilde is me I is
mu I time G tilde times G prime of UI
and and then that was just an artificial
thing so that we could actually divide
the weights by G prime but the real
thing that built the weights are this H
prime and there's this normalization
factor and so if we write it like that
so if I also write that WI is H prime of
X I transpose beta divided by G prime of
MU I times Phi then I could actually
rewrite my gradient which is a vector in
the following matrix form the gradient
ln @ beta the gradient of my log
likelihood of beta took the following
form it was x transpose w and then y
tilde minus mu Chola and here w was just
a matrix with W 1 W 2 all the way to W
and on the diagonal and 0 on the off
diagonals ok
so that was just taking the derivative
and doing a slight manipulations that
said well let's just divide whatever's
here by G prime and multiply whatever's
here by G prime so today we'll see why
we make this division and multiplication
by G prime which seems to make no sense
but it actually comes from the Hessian
computations so the Hessian computations
are gonna be a little more annoying
actually let me start directly with the
coordinate wise derivative right so to
build this gradient what we used in the
end was that the partial derivative of
Ln with respect to the Jade coordinate
of beta was equal to the sum over I of Y
I tailed a minus mu I tilde times WI
times the J's coordinates of X I
okay so now let's just take another
derivative and that's going to give us
the entries of the Hessian okay so we're
doing it we're going to the second
derivative so what I want to compute is
the derivative with respect to beta J
and beta K okay so where does beta J so
here I already took the derivative with
respect to beta J so this is just the
derivative with respect to beta K of the
derivative with respect to beta J so
what I need to do is to take the
derivative of this guy with respect to
beta K where does better case show up
here it's said in in two places no it's
not in the wise the wise are my are my
data right but I mean it's in the white
childers yeah because it's in new right
new depends on beta mu is G inverse of X
I transpose beta and it's also in in the
W is actually everything that you see is
directly well ok W depends on new end of
on beta explicitly and but the rest
depends only on mu and so we might want
to be a little well we can actually I
use the did we did I use the chain rule
already yeah it's here but okay
well let's let's go for it so
oh yeah okay sorry I should not write it
like that because that was actually
right so I make my life miserable by
just multiplying and dividing by this G
prime of MU I should not do this right
so what I should just write is say that
this guy here I'm actually gonna remove
the MU prime the G prime of MU because I
just make something that depends on
theta appear when it really should not
so let's just look at the last but one
equality okay so that's the one over
there and then I have X IJ okay so here
it make my life much more simple because
Y I does not depend on beta but this guy
depends on beta and this guy depends on
beta all right so when I take the
derivative I'm gonna have to be a little
more careful now but I just have a
derivative of a product nothing more
complicated so this is what well the sum
is gonna be linear so it's going to come
out then I'm going to have to take the
derivative of this term so it's just
going to be 1 over psi then the
derivative of MU I with respect to beta
K which I will just write like this
times H prime of X I transpose beta X IJ
and then I'm gonna have the other one
which is mu Y I minus mu I over 5 times
the second derivative of H of X
transpose X I transpose beta and then
I'm going to take the derivative of this
guy with respect to beta J with beta K
which is just X I K so I have X IJ times
X I K ok so I still need to compute this
guy so what is the partial derivative
with respect to beta K of G so mu is G
of a sorry is G inverse of X I transpose
beta
okay so what do I get
well I'm gonna get definitely the second
derivative of G well okay that's
actually not a bad idea
well no that's okay I can make the
second what makes my life easier
actually there's no one that actually
makes my life so much easier
let's just write it that's good with
this guy so it's gonna be G prime prime
of X I transposed beta times X I K okay
so now what do I have if I collect my
terms I have that this whole thing here
the second derivative is well I have the
sum from 1 equal 1/2 and then I have
terms that I can factor out right both
of these guys have X IJ and this guy
pulls out an X I K and it's also here X
IJ times X I K right so everybody here
is X IJ X I K and now I just have to
take the terms that I have here the 1
over Phi I can actually pull out in
front and I'm left with the second
derivative of G times the first
derivative of H both taking at X I
transpose beta and then I have this Y I
minus mu I times the second derivative
of H taken at X I transpose beta
okay but here I'm looking at Fischer
scoring I'm not looking at Newton's
method which means that I can actually
take the expectation of the second
derivative so when I start taking the
expectation what's going to happen so if
I take the expectation of this whole
thing here well this guy is not
and when I say expectation it's always
conditionally on X I so let's write it X
1 X n so like I take conditional this is
just deterministic but what is the
conditional expectation of Y I minus nu
I times this guy conditionally on X I 0
right because this is just a conditional
expectation of Y I and everything else
depends on X I only so I can push it out
of the conditional expectation so I'm
left only with this term okay now so now
I need to sorry and I have xixj X okay x
IG x IQ okay so now I want to I want to
go to something that's slightly more
convenient for me so maybe we can skip
that part here because this is not gonna
be convenient for me anyway so I just
want to go back to something that looks
eventually like this okay that's what
I'm gonna want so I need to have my X I
show up with some weight somehow and the
weight should involve H prime divided by
G prime okay and the reason why I want
to see G prime coming back is because I
had G prime coming in the original W
this is actually the same definition as
the W's that I used when I was computing
the gradient right those are exactly the
we'll use those guys so I need to have G
Prime that shows up and that's where I'm
gonna have to make a little bit of
computation here and it's coming from
this kind of from this kind of
considerations okay
so this thing here Oh actually I'm
missing the Phi of a there right there
should be a Phi here okay so we have
exactly this thing because this tells me
that if I look at the Hessian so this
was entry wise and this is exactly the
form of something of the four of the K
this is exactly the Jake case entry of
xixi transpose right we've used that
before so if I want to write this in a
vector form this is just going to be the
sum of something in that depends on I
times X I X I transpose so this is 1
over Phi sum from I equal 1 to N of G
prime prime X I transpose beta H prime X
I transpose beta X I X I transpose okay
and that's for the entire matrix here
that was just the JK entries of this
matrix and you can just check that if I
take this matrix the jth entry is just
the product of the Jade coordinate and
the case coordinate of X I all right
so now I need to do my rewriting can I
write this so I'm missing something here
right
oh I know where it's coming from
new is not G prime of X P de new is G
inverse of X P de right so derivative of
X prime is not it's not G prime prime
it's it's like this guy no one over this
right okay
the derivative of G inverse is 1 over G
prime of G inverse I need you guys ok
I'm not alright so now I'm gonna have to
rewrite this this guy is still gonna go
away it doesn't matter but now this
thing is becoming H prime over G prime
of G inverse of X I transpose beta which
is the same here which is the same here
okay everybody approves all right but
now it's actually much nicer what is G
inverse of X I transpose beta well that
was exactly the mistake that I just made
right it's new I itself so this guy is
really G prime of MU I this sorry just
the bottom right so now I have something
which looks like and some from icon one
to n of H prime of X I transpose beta
divided by G prime of U I Phi times X I
X I transpose which I can certainly
write in matrix form as X transpose W X
where W is exactly the same as before so
it's W 1 W N and W I is H prime of X I
transpose beta divided by G prime of MU
I there's a prime here times Phi which
is the same that we had here and
supposed to be the same that we have
here except that the Phi's in white okay
[Music]
all right so it's actually simpler than
what's on the slides I guess all right
so now if you pay attention I actually
never forced this G prime of MU I to be
here
should I even try to make a mistake to
not have it and so this G prime of U
shows up completely naturally if I had
started with this you would have never
questioned the
the why I actually did multiply by G
prime and divided by G Prime completely
artificially here it just shows up
naturally in the weights but just more
natural for me to compute the first
derivative first and the second
derivative second okay and so and so we
just did it the other way around but now
let's assume we forgot about everything
we have this this is a natural way of
writing it X transpose W X if I want
something that involves some weights I
have to sort of force them in by
dividing by G prime of MU I and
therefore multiplying Y I mu I by this
WI okay so now if we recap what we've
actually found we got that let me write
it here we also have that the
expectation of H Ln of B now X transpose
X W so if I go back to my adorations
over there I should actually update beta
K plus 1 to be equal to beta K plus the
inverse so that's actually equal to
negative I of beta K well yeah that's
negative I of B you know I guess so so
that's gonna be oh and beta here shows
up in W right W depends on beta so
that's gonna be beta K so let me call it
W K so that's the diagonal of H prime X
I transpose beta K this time divided by
G prime of MU I J Phi okay so this mu
induce this beta K induces a mu by
looking at G inverse of X I transpose
beta K all right so mu I K
is G inverse of X I transpose beta K
that's an iteration and so now if I
actually write these things together I
get minus X transpose W X inverse so
that's W K and then I have my great my
gradient here that I have to apply at K
which is X transpose wk and then I have
white other K minus mu tilde K where
again the indices I mean the superscript
K are pretty natural Y tilde K just
means that so that's just Y I so that's
just why I times G prime of mu I K mu
well and new tilde K is if I look at the
I coordinate is just gonna be mu I times
G prime of MU I okay so I just add
superscripts K to everything so I know
that those things get updated real time
right every time I have I make one
iteration I get a new value for beta I
get a new value from you and therefore I
get a new value for W yes yeah that's a
good point
so that's definitely a plus because this
is a positive semi definite matrix so
this is a plus and where did I well
that's probably where I erased it
[Music]
okay let's see where I made my mistake
so this there should be a - here there
should be a - here there should be -
even at the beginning I believe so that
means that what is my oh yeah yeah so
you see when we go back to the first so
what I erased was basically this thing
here why I minus mu I and when I took
the first derivative so there was the
derivative with respect to H prime so
the derivative the spec - the second
term I mean the really of the second
term was actually killed because we took
the expectation of this guy
when we took the derivative of the first
time which is the only one that stayed
this guy went away but there was a
negative sign from this guy because
that's the thing which you didn't get
evolved so it's really when I take my
second derivative I should carry out
some minus signs everywhere
okay so it's just I had I forgot this -
throw so if you write and you see that
the first term went away on the first
line there the first term went away
because the conditional expectation of Y
given X is zero and then they had this
minus sign in front of everyone
and I forgot it all right any other
mistake that I made good all right so
now this is what we have that XK so
sorry that beta K plus 1 is equal to
beta k plus this thing okay and if you
look at this thing it sort of reminds us
of something it's sort of remember the
least squares estimator so here I'm
going to actually deviate slightly from
the slides and I will tell you how the
slides take beta K and put it in here
which is one way to go and just think of
this as a big least square solution or
you can keep the beta K solve another so
silver and other least squares and then
add it to the beta key that you have
it's the same thing so I will take the
different routes so you have the two
options all right
okay so when we did the least-squares so
parentheses least squares we had y
equals x beta plus epsilon and our
estimator beta hat was x transpose X
inverse X transpose Y right and that was
just solving the first-order condition
and that's what we found now look at
this X transpose bleep X inverse X
transpose bleep something okay so this
looks like if this is the same as the
left board if WK is equal to the
identity matrix meaning we don't see it
and Y is equal to Y tilde K minus mutual
decay so those similarities the fact
that we just squeezed in so the fact
that the response variable is different
is really not a problem we just have to
pretend that this is equal to Y tilde
minus mu children and that's just the
least squares when you call a software
that does least squares for you you just
tell it what Y is you tell it what X is
that it makes the computation so you
would just lie to it and say all the
actual Y I want is this way and then we
need to somehow incorporate those
weights and so the question is is that
easy to do and the answer is yes because
this is a set up where you would act
this would actually arise a lot so one
of the things that's very specific to
what we did here and with least squares
we'll assume that epsilon when we did at
least the inference we assume that
epsilon was normal zero and the
covariance matrix was the identity right
what if the covariance matrix is not yet
identity if the covariance matrix is not
the identity then your maximum
likelihood is not exactly this
least-squares if the covariance matrix
is any matrix you have another solution
which involves the inverse of the
covariance matrix that you have but if
your convenience matrix in particular is
diagonal which would mean that each
observations that you get in the system
of equations is still independent but
the variances can change from one line
to another from one observation to
another then it's called heteroskedastic
hetero means you know not the same
Scholastica's scale and heteroscedastic
case you would have slightly something
slightly different and it's sort of it
sort of makes sense that if you know
that some observations have much less
variance than others you might want to
give them more weight okay so if you
think about your you know usual drawing
and maybe you have something like this
and you know and but the actual line is
really okay let's say you have this guy
as well okay like if you start drawing
this thing it's gonna be that if you do
least squares you're gonna see something
that looks like this on those points but
now if I tell you that on this side the
variance is equal to 100 meaning that
those points are actually really far
from the true one and here on this side
the variance is equal to 1 meaning that
those points are actually close to the
line you're looking for then the line
you should be fitting is probably this
guy meaning did not trust the guys that
have a lot of variance and so you need
somehow to incorporate that if you know
that those things have much more
variance than this guy's you want to
weight this and the way you do it is by
using weighted least squares okay so
we're gonna open in parentheses on
weighted least squares it's not a
fundamental statistical question but
it's useful for us because this is
exactly what's gonna spit out something
that looks like this with this matrix W
in there
okay so let's you know go back in time
for a second assume we're still covering
the squares regression so now I'm going
to assume that Y is X beta plus Epsilon
this time epsilon is a multivariate
Gaussian in say P dimensions with mean 0
and covariance matrix I will write it as
W inverse because W is gonna be the one
that's gonna show up okay so this is the
so-called heteroskedastic that's how
it's spelled and you know yet another
name that you can pick for your soccer
team or you know a cappella group all
right so the maximum likelihood in this
case so actually let's compute the
maximum likelihood for this problem
right so the luck likelihood is what
well we're gonna have the term that
tells us that it's gonna be so okay what
is the density of a multivariate
Gaussian so it's going to be a
multivariate Gaussian in P dimension
with mean X beta and covariance matrix W
inverse right so that's the density that
we want well it's of the form 1 over
determinant of W inverse times 2 pi to
the P over 2
okay and times exponential and now what
I have is X minus X beta transpose W so
that's the inverse of W inverse X minus
X beta divided by 2 okay so this is X
minus mu transpose Sigma inverse X minus
mu divided by 2 and if you want to
sanity check just assume that Sigma yeah
well you know if you want this to be Y
then this is Y right sure yes maybe it's
less confusing so if you do P is equal
to 1 then what does it mean it means
that you have this mean here so let's
forget about what it is
this guy is gonna be just 1 Sigma
squared right so what you see here is
the inverse of Sigma squared so that's
going to be 2 over 2 Sigma squared like
we usually see it the determinant of W
inverse is just the product of the entry
of the 1 by 1 matrix which is just one
of us which is just Sigma square ok so
that should be actually yeah no that's
actually yeah that's Sigma square and
then I have this 2pi so square root of
this because P is equal to 1 I get Sigma
square root 2 pi which is the
normalization that I get this is not
going to matter because when I look at
the log likelihood as a function of beta
so I'm assuming that W is known what I
get is something which is a constant so
it's minus P minus n times P over 2
times log that W inverse times 2 pi ok
so this is just gonna be a constant it
won't matter when I do the maximum
likelihood and then I'm gonna have what
I'm gonna have plus 1/2 of Y minus X
beta transpose w Y minus X beta so if I
want to take the minimum the maximum of
this guy
sorry there's a minus here so if I want
to take the maximum of this guy I'm
going to have to take the minimum of
this thing and the minimum of this thing
if you take the derivatives you get to
see so that's the that's what we have
right we need to compute the minimum of
Y minus X beta transpose W minus X Y
minus X beta and the solution that you
get I mean you can actually check this
for yourself the way you can see this is
by doing the following if you're lazy
and you don't want to redo the entire
thing
w is diagonal right I'm going to assume
that so W inverse is diagonal and I'm
going to assume that no variance is
equal to zero and no variance is equal
to infinity so that both W inverse and W
have only positive entries on the
diagonal all right so in particular I
can talk about the square root of W
which is just the matrix the diagonal
matrix with the square roots on the
diagonal okay and so I want to minimize
in beta Y minus X beta transpose W Y
minus X beta so I'm gonna write W as
square root of W times square root of W
which I can because W and it's just the
simplest thing right if W is W 1 W n so
that's my W then square root of W is
just square root of W 1 square root of W
N and then zeros elsewhere okay so the
product of those two matrices gives me
definitely back what I want and that's
the usual matrix product now what I'm
going to do is I'm going to push one on
one side and push the other one on the
other side so that gives me that this is
really the minimum over beta of well
here I have this transpose so I have to
put it on the other side W is clearly
symmetric and square root so is square
root of W so the transpose doesn't
matter and so what I'm left with the
square root of W why minus square root
of W X beta transpose and then times
itself so that's square root W Y minus
square roots W you know space X beta
okay and that stops here but this is the
same thing that we've been doing before
this is a new Y let's call it Y prime
this is a new X let's call it X prime
and now this is just the least squares
estimator associated to a response Y
prime and a design matrix X prime so I
know that the solution is
prime transpose X prime inverse X prime
transpose Y Prime and I'm just gonna
substitute again what my X prime is in
terms of X and what my Y prime is in
terms of Y and that gives me exactly X W
squared W squared W X inverse and then I
have X transpose square root W for this
guy and then I have square root W Y for
that guy and that's exactly what I
wanted
I'm left with X transpose W X inverse X
transpose W Y okay so that's a simple
way to take into account the W that we
had before and you could actually do it
with any matrix that's positive semi
definite because you can actually talk
about the square root of those matrices
it's just the square root of a matrix is
just a matrix such that when you
multiply it by itself it gives you the
original matrix okay so here that was
just a shortcut into that consisted in
saying okay maybe I don't want to
recompute the gradient of this quantity
set it equal to zero and see what beta
hat should be I instead I'm going to
assume that I already know that if I did
not have the W I would know how to solve
it and that's exactly what I did I said
well let's I know that this is the
minimum of something that looks like
this when they have the primes and then
I just substitute back my W in there
alright so it's just the lazy
computation but again if you don't like
it you can always take the gradient of
this guy yes because there's a mistake
yeah there's a mistake on the slides
how did I make that one I'm actually
trying to parse it back
I mean it's clearly wrong right oh no
it's not
no it is so it's not clearly wrong
actually it is clearly wrong because if
I put the identity here those are still
associative right so this product is
actually not compatible so it's wrong
there's just this extra thing that I
probably copy-paste it from someplace
since this is one of my latest line I'll
just color it in white and but yeah
sorry there's this this parenthesis is
not here thank you
yeah okay because I have two of them I
have one that comes from the ex-prime
that's here this guy and then I have one
that comes from the this guy here okay
so the solution let's write it in
someplace that's actually eligible which
is the correction for this thing is X
transpose W X inverse X transpose W Y
okay so you just squeezing this W in
there and that's exactly what we had
before
X transpose W X inverse X transpose W
some Y okay and when I claim is that
this is really to routinely implemented
as you can imagine heteroscedastic
linear regression is something that's
very common so every time you have a
least squares formula you also have a
way to put in some weights you can you
don't have to put diagonal weights but
here that's all we need and so here on
the slides again I took the beta K and I
put it in there so that I have only one
least square solution to formulate but
let's do it slightly differently what
I'm gonna do here now is I'm gonna say
okay let's feed to some least squares so
let's do weighted least squares on
response Y being white shell decay -
mutual decay and design matrix being
well just X itself so that doesn't
change and and the weights so the
weights are what the weights are the WK
that I had here so W K I is H prime of X
I transpose beta K divided by G prime of
MU I at time k times Phi ok and so I
this if I solve it will spit out
something that I will call a solution I
will call it U hat k plus 1 and to get
beta hat k plus 1 all I need to do is to
do beta K + u hat k plus 1 that's sorry
beta yeah okay and that's because so
here that's not clear but I started from
there remember I started from this guy
here so I'm just solving at least Curtis
and weighted least square that's gonna
give me this thing that's what I called
u hat k plus 1 and then I added to be
the key and that gives me beta K minus 1
so I just have this intermediate step
which is removed in the slides ok
so then you can repeat until convergence
what it mean to repeat until convergence
yeah exactly so you just set some
threshold and you say I promise you that
this will converge right so you know
that at some point you're going to be
there but you're gonna go there but
you're never going to be exactly there
and so you just say okay I want this
accuracy on my beta actually the machine
is a little strong right especially if
you have ten observations to start with
you know you're gonna have something
that's gonna be that's gonna have some
statistical error so that should
actually guide you into what kind of
error you want to be making so for
example a good rule of thumb is that if
you have n observations you just take
some within if you want the l2 distance
between the beta the two consecutive
beta to be less than one over n you
should be good enough it doesn't have to
be the person machine precision and so
it's clear how we do this right so here
I have I just have to maintain a bunch
of things right so remember when I want
to recompute every at every step I have
to recompute a bunch of things so I have
to recompute the waist but if I want to
recompute the weight not only do I need
the previous error rate but I need to
know how to previous iterate impacts my
my means so at each step I have to
recalculate new I K by doing G prime
right remember mu I K was just G prime G
inverse of X I transpose beta K right so
I have to recompute that and then I use
this to compute my weight I also use
this to compute my Y right so my Y
depends also on G prime of MU I K I feed
that to my weighted least squares engine
it spits out that you had K that I add
to my previous Vedic a and that gives me
my new beta k plus 1 okay so here's the
pseudocode if you want to take some time
to parse it
all right so here again the trick is not
much it's just saying if you don't feel
like implementing Fischer scoring or
inverting your Hessian at every step
then a weighted least squares is
actually gonna do it for you
automatically right and that's just a
numerical trick there's nothing really
statistical about this except the fact
that you know this closed form solution
for each of the step reminded us of
reminded us of some of these squares and
except that there was some extra weights
ok so to conclude for - well need to
know of course X Y the link function why
do we need the variance function I'm not
sure we actually need the variance
function no you need Phi not the
variance function so where do you start
actually right so clearly if you start
very close to your solution you're
actually going to do much better and one
good way to start so for the beta itself
it's not clear what it's gonna be but
you can actually get a good idea of what
beta is by just having a good idea of
what mu is because mu is G inverse of X
I transpose beta and so what you could
do is to try to set mu to be the actual
observations that you have because you
know that's the best guess that you have
for their expected value and then you
just say okay once I have my mu I know
that my mu is a function of this thing
so I can write G of mu and solve it
using your least squares estimator right
so G of mu is of the form X data so you
just solve for once you have your mu you
pass it through G and then you solve for
the beta that you want and then that's
the beta that you initialize with okay
and actually this was your question from
last time as soon as I use the canonical
link Fisher scoring and newton-raphson
or the
thing because the Hessian is actually
deterministic in that case just because
when we took this when the H in when you
use the canonical link H is the identity
which means that its second derivative
is equal to zero so this term goes away
even without taking the expectation all
right so remember the term that went
away was of the form Y I minus mu I
divided by Phi times H prime prime of X
I transposed beta right that's the term
that we said oh the conditional
expectation of this guy is 0 but if H
prime prime is already go to 0 then
there's nothing that changes there's
nothing that goes away it was already
equal to 0 and that always happen when
you have the canonical link because H is
G prime is G V prime inverse and G is
equal to be the canonical link is V
prime inverse so this thing is easy
identity so the second derivative of Y
of f of X is equal to X is 0
ok my screen says end of show so we can
start with some questions related ly
squares that's an implementation that's
just making calls to weighted least
squares or calls it's called the Oracle
sometimes an Oracle is what you assume
the machine can do easily for you so if
you assume that your machine is very
good at you know multiplying by the
inverse of a matrix you might as well
just do Fisher in scoring yourself right
it's just a way so that you don't have
to actually do it and those things
usually those things are implemented and
I just said routinely in statistical
software but they were mended if very
efficiently in software so this is going
to be one of the fastest ways you're
gonna have to solve to to do this step
especially for large scale problems
so if you were to do this in the
simplest possible way right your
iterations for the waited for essay
fever scoring is just multiplied by the
inverse of the future information right
yeah so it takes a bit of time whereas
since you know you're gonna multiply it
directly by something if you just say
those things are not as optimized as
solving least squares actually the way
it's typically done is by doing some of
these queries so you might as well just
do the least squares that you like and
there's also less well no there's no
well there is less free computer
calculation right here you Fisher you
would have to recompute the entire
matrix of Fisher information where I see
you don't have to write you really just
have to compute like some vectors and
the vector of weights right so the
Fisher information matrix has say and
choose two entries that you need to
compute right it's symmetric so it's
order N squared entries but here the
only things you update if you think
about it are this weights matrix so
there's only the diagonal elements that
you need to update and these vectors and
they're also so those are our size
there's two n versus n squared so
there's much less thing to actually put
in there it does it for you somehow any
other question
all right so yeah
yeah you can well not exactly right
because the GE also shows up in this
correction that you have here right I
mean I don't know what you mean by yeah
I mean Wow okay there's the
heteroskedastic case for sure so if you
can actually compute those things and
you know more generally I don't think
you should think of those as being
weights you should really think of those
as being matrices that you invert and
don't think of it as being diagonal but
really think of them as being like full
matrices so if you have right when we
wrote weighted least squares here this
was really the W I said is diagonal but
all the computations really never really
use the fact that it's diagonal so this
is what you what shows up here is just
the inverse of your convenience matrix
and so if you have data that's
correlated this is where it's going to
show up